fait toucher le beau geste que vous avez
fait vous d'un jour dans votre vie ne
sont pas les gestes
alors moi j'en ai fait je crois que c
est considéré comme un beau jesse j'ai
un jour un de mes amis qui m'a appelé en
me disant on est viré de l'appartement
n'a plus un rond etc et je les ai reçu
avec son épouse ils sont restés quatre
ans dans mon appartement à paris 80
oui quatre ans mais c'était sympa
finalement il était voilà bah ouais j'ai
la chance d'avoir deux chambres dont
qu'ils étaient au fond tranquille et
c'était terrible de les laisser donc je
vais d'histoire l'année mais bravo
bernard iv maxime quand je sais pas
aussi si c'est un beau geste mais je
vais assez souvent dans les hôpitaux
faire des tours de magie aux enfants
malades à qui ont marché à l'hôpital qui
réalise des rêves d'enfant pour les
sortir de leur quotidien d'un bravo
valérie ma chérie du public oui vous
avez déjà fait un beau geste vous oui
j'ai déjà offert des prestations quand
j'étais thérapeute énergéticienne à des
personnes qui avaient pas qu'elle
enquêtait pas bien et qu'ils avaient
besoin de deux d'être massé d'être voilà
d'avoir ma bravo bravo jean michel je
n'ai pas fait au final mais j'avais
proposé de donner un organe à quelqu'un
que je connais très bien qu'ils aient
voilà qui avait besoin de greffe
bon j'étais pas compatibles mais je
m'étais proposé de le donner et ça
franchement alors ça va merci je vous
demande pas je demande pour d'autres
parce que je sais que c'est non la garde
ouais est-ce que je peux juste me
permettre de donner le nom d'une
association dont je suis la marraine et
bien sûr peu de pub ça s'appelle juste
humain c'est une association qui
s'occupe des enfants dans les hôpitaux
et qui vient apporter justement de la
culture du sur la mode un peu de choses
festive ya normalement il devrait y
avoir il y aurait dû avoir la semaine de
la mode dont les enfants font leurs
vêtements il défie il ya des mânes des
maquilleurs et des maquilleuses qui
viennent et c'est donc voilà c'est une
association toute petite qui s'appelle
justement j'en suis la marraine est sûre
exemple faire que tu parlais de dont moi
un moment donné je faisais des trucs jeu
sera et à un pote qui travaillent dans
les distributeurs automatiques sahel et
sandwich triangle tout ça savait que
qu'à deux jours que ces deux dates de
péremption
il est prêt ni les fous dans un sac
poubelle ils les jettent et moi je les
prenais jallet devant l'hôpital de
nanterre et genève qui avait beaucoup
des sdf et je n'ai beaucoup de sang mais
ce serait bien qu'un jour les
associations elles viennent et qu'elles
récupèrent ce serait l'enfer
moi je suis travailleur s'est souvenu
avec l'est du caire c'est ce qu'ils font
chaque année c'est ce qu'ils font enfin
il récupère des machines automatiques
avec
tous les grands d'hypermarchés etc il
récuse les invendus les peut-être
allez-vous et puis vous êtes